I was just found out like two hours ago
that it was your birthday yeah what did
you do to celebrate your birthday
nothing nothing no no no you'd have a
party now get together with friends no I
know I know it's fine birthdays are fine
I'm not like a big birthday person I'd
cry I usually cry wait how are you
crying
yeah think about all the things I
haven't done and all the things I won't
get to do won't get to do you're a young
woman with your whole life ahead of you
know about your tongue like you've got
well you know just a month to go that's
how I see things so you just cry did you
do anything to June I watched a game of
Thrones and I haven't even watched the
rest of the episodes I just watched one
episode very confused so you didn't know
I mean I've watched them all and I still
get kinky no I was just crying and
watching it going well people like this
so why doesn't this make me happy yeah
even this like does anyone want to be
around you on your birthday I think the
worst person to hang out with on a
birthday no I'm just counting down the
minutes until it's over I just can't
it's like I just been staring at the
clock the whole time
well what okay have you ever had like a
party with Connie Miller have you ever
done that have you ever had like oh
let's have a party let's have cocktails
let's have drinks for myself
yeah no no okay all right is it just
your birthday that you're like this or
is this every day of your life I don't
know what it is a day you know
what are we doing I want to kill myself
give us here did you at least have cake
yeah no but I did do it I did have a fun
wall on Friday did a Anna Faris's
podcast and we had little Parks and Rec
reunion and Retta and Chris Pratt were
there and they got me cupcakes oh that
was great it's very nice and yeah so
there you go there's your there's a
birthday thing yeah
you satisfied it's holy you almost did
that just so all right now get off my
back I did something for my birthday we
had some cupcakes now shut up about it
it wasn't my idea but yeah people did it
to me so okay let's move on okay
you